sometimes the entire year's return comes
in just a few days
and if you're not invested in those days
you miss out
your 20s and 30s are prime earning years
the longer you wait the less you will
have in retirement
so it's best you get started right now
[Music]
well it's that time of the year again
and i thought it would be a terrific
time to have well the classic fireside
chat
i want to talk about everybody's future
the scariest thing for me
for anybody is to end up at the age of
65
with nothing in the bank in other words
no investment
strategy no retirement fund nothing
and you know the truth is not everybody
knows how to build a long-term
diversified portfolio and i totally get
that
you know i was really stunned during the
whole pandemic thing in march and april
when i found
out when we did the whole ppp payroll
loan thing
how many of the people in my
organization my employees and other
supply chain entities
that i work with you know all those
people in their 20s and 30s
nothing put aside for the future that
is scary so let's talk about that
because i don't want that to be you
you know at the end of the day you've
really got to think about your future
because
i think no one else is going to do it
for you everybody loves to procrastinate
i don't want to work out today i don't
want to go for a walk
i don't want to start investing there's
always a reason not to do
something and it's your enemy when it
comes to investing
you really want to get over that quickly
because you need the time
value of money to be on your side so
don't procrastinate
start investing find a way to get
discipline put some aside every week
and let it grow for you you're not doing
it for somebody else you're doing it for
you
so when you end up in your 60s you have
something set aside
when people say when should i start
investing my answer is always the same
now now is the time why
because it takes time usually many many
years for investments to grow
and to build your wealth so you've got
to have a long-term strategy
investing can feel really overwhelming
especially when it's
your first time if you've never done
this before it can be scary
ideally you would have started yesterday
but there's no point in dwelling on the
past
let's get started today the most
important step
in the process is to make a commitment
to yourself
and your own future more than a hundred
million americans
don't have any investment accounts
that's crazy that's one-third of the
population doing
nothing for retirement doing nothing to
grow their wealth
huge problem you don't want to be one of
them if you start now
you can give your investments more time
and really start to grow your money
think about this
if you invest a hundred dollars a week
every week
not just saving but investing assuming
markets generate growth similar to the
past
30 40 years which has been roughly
around 8 percent
and you invested in a diversified
portfolio
and reinvested your dividends you could
have a million and a half bucks
in the bank in 40 years with just a
hundred dollars
a week is that too hard to do
the longer you wait the less you will
have in retirement
so it's best you get started right now
let's talk about the challenge of doing
it
it's easier than it's ever been before
why because a lot of technology exists
to help you out
it's easier than before because you
don't need to know a lot about
investing to be an investor too many
people seem afraid to invest
because they don't feel like experts
that's why i decided to create bean
stocks
to create an app that does almost all
the investing
for you all of it using your phone and
the beanstalk application
it's really really easy and it costs
only five
dollars a month now here's how it works
step one download beanstalks onto your
phone
or click on the first link in the
description below to get started
step two in the app you'll answer some
basic questions
about your financial goals and risk
tolerance
levels and how much you'd like to invest
to start
and how much automatically each week or
each month
you want to set up the app will then let
you connect your bank account
it's safe and secure and then confirm
how much you want to invest today
the minimum amount is a hundred dollars
and you decide after that how much you
want to set up
as an automatic recurring investment
although there's no minimum for the
reoccurring investment i recommend you
take it seriously and commit a recurring
investment
remember it's for you it's your future
step four
once you've done steps one two and three
and approve the proposed portfolio for
you
you're all set you can now let the
investing
happen once your money gets deposited we
invest it for you in a diversified
portfolio
that's right for you based on your
profile
i have a team of experienced investment
professionals that carefully
craft and monitor the portfolios they
work hard on this so you don't have to
they're the experts and as the
investments earn dividend income
the cash is also invested for you that's
what it's all about
long term that's great
so there's really no excuse for not
starting today
you don't need to know a lot about
investing to be an investor
all you need is a phone the beanstalks
app and a bank account
that's what you need a phone the app and
a bank account download beanstalks
b-e-a-n-s-t-o-x it's all in the app
stores
i mean how easy is that so you might ask
why start now after the market's gone up
here's what i tell them and i've learned
this the hard way you can't
time the market sometimes the entire
year's return comes in just a few days
and if you're not invested in those days
you miss out
you have to get used to volatility the
market going up and down
but don't try and time it nobody gets
that right
remember when the pandemic started
people panicked and markets dropped
some people thought their investments
were doomed but what actually happened
the market came back as they've done
after every major drop in history
am i predicting what will happen
tomorrow no absolutely not
why because nobody knows i don't have a
crystal ball and either do
other investors and financial advisors
out there the most
important thing to remember is that
investing is a
long term game when i started putting
money in the markets
i'd obsessively check my portfolio every
hour until the closing bell rang
what a waste of time energy insanity
if you want your money to grow you have
to be in the markets
consistently over time volatility
corrections and bear markets
are all to be expected if you look back
at historical market data
over the past few decades you'll see
that the line isn't straight but overall
it does
trend upwards investments in healthcare
have done really well in recent months
but high investment returns for some
securities have been on just a couple of
trading days the key here is patience is
a virtue in the investing world
you're not getting any younger let's
face it do i really need to start
investing now you might ask yourself
can i wait a year until i make more
money
your 20s and 30s are prime earning years
make the most out of them and the money
you're bringing in now
so you can enjoy your life later it's
going to be a lot harder to put in extra
hours at the office or start a side gig
when you're my age and you don't want to
have to do that
you want a long-term plan we're talking
about it right now prioritize your
finances
when you're young and you'll get ahead
of the game why is this important
let's talk about it savings versus
investing
and the time value of money if you start
putting away a hundred dollars a week as
we talked about earlier
and you just save that money in your
bank account assuming historical
simple savings rates in forty years
you will have accumulated approximately
two hundred and eight thousand dollars
now let's talk about investing that
money that sounds like a lot
but if you invest that money and those
are invested in the markets where the
gains are eight percent a year
have been historically an annualized
return of eight percent
think about this in 40 years you will
have accumulated over a million
and a half bucks that's why it's
important to start now
put your money to work for you so when
it comes to long-term planning
now is the time to do it i hope you've
enjoyed this
fireside chat today because i'm hoping
it gets you
past procrastinating and you start
thinking about yourself and your own
future
and you find the discipline to put at
least a hundred dollars a week aside
you know you can do it you really can
there's something you don't need to buy
instead of buying it invest in yourself
invest in yourself for the long term
[Music]
i think he's coming in
that bird is aggressive
[Applause]
we defended the fort
[Music]
if you like that video wait did you see
my next one
don't forget to click right over here
and subscribe